imminent credible lethal that was the
warning from the uk just hours before
the threat of an attack became a reality
two seemingly coordinated bombings
against us-led troops and the taliban
civilians paying the heaviest price
the target was a massive western
evacuation effort at kabul airport
the attackers struck outside the
perimeter towards the end of the day
one bomb possibly a suicide blast ripped
through crowds of afghans near the
barren hotel here
a key assembly point for anyone trying
to access rescue flights to the uk
gunfire followed possibly from troops
responding to the blast
there was also an explosion at abbey
gate that killed 12 u.s service
personnel
a suicide bomber is suspected of
detonating themselves at or near an
entry point where body searches take
place
afghans who've been using this sewage
canal while waiting to be evacuated also
exposed
the terrorist group islamic state has
claimed responsibility its afghanistan
affiliate isis k
is an enemy of the taliban as well as
western powers we're handing back the
country to the very insurgency uh that
we went in defeat but now we actually
see that this insurgency that's wanted
to take over the country can't control
the country and that's been illustrated
by this devastating attack today
terrorist groups now resuming what they
do uh best to cause harm not just to the
west in this case but also to afghans as
well so this is a very very dark chapter
that we now leave afghanistan in the uk
and allies leaving under the shadow of a
terrorist attack 20 years on from an
invasion that was meant to stop this
country being used as a haven for
terrorism it's supremely ironic uh but
it's not remotely humorous no it's
tragic and um
it comes back to the
essential question of what we were doing
in afghanistan were we there to nation
build or were we just there to prevent
it being a base for terrorism and the
two come up with completely different
answers we've been trying to
nation-build for 20 years and i think
this shows the failure of that no
comfort for those left behind like this
former interpreter for british forces
his desperation to catch an evacuation
flight meant he was willing to risk the
terrorist threat at the airport with his
family including his three-month-old
daughter we spoke a couple of hours
before the blasts and what will you do
if you cannot get onto one of these
flights
if i don't get one of these lights i
will be lost completely lost so i i
don't know i don't have any idea where
to go this is just like i'm in hell
he and his family escaped the carnage
but his hopes to escape his country
fading fast debra haines sky news